this past Saturday as the overwatch
league was set to restart its schedule
the Boston uprising announced that one
of their tank players muffin would not
be competing with the team and that's
because just a day earlier he was
accused of sexual misconduct and
soliciting nude photos from underage
women this story is very complicated
[Music]
this all started last Saturday when like
I said the Boston uprising tweeted out
that muffin would not be competing with
them in their first game since the kovat
shut down their reasoning was quote
allegations against movement and they
said that they wouldn't be commenting on
the situation any further until an
investigation was carried out well it
turns out that those allegations were
pretty serious multiple people on
Twitter were alleging that muffin was
engaging in sexual misconduct and being
sexually inappropriate towards - this
situation was first brought to light on
Twitter by a user named its father who
claimed that there was an overwatch
league player quote preying on kids they
went on to claim that his team Boston
had been aware of this situation
previously a day later we got the whole
story a twitch streamer named Khaleesi
released a twit longer detailing her
entire relationship with muffin and all
of the allegations being waged against
it in the post she describes her
friendship and eventual short-lived
romantic relationship with movies at
first what she describes isn't really
unusual at all the two of them met
online and became very close but never
spent any time face-to-face with that
said they developed feelings for one
another and eventually decided to be
exclusive but that's when police he says
that she started to get warnings from
friends and acquaintances saying that
he'd been reaching out to other women
asking for nude photos and then in July
she got a similar warning except this
time one of the girls he was asking was
allegedly underage now to be as clear as
possible about the allegations here
Khaleesi
was alleging that mu Fionn whose age is
not public but he must be over 18 to be
in the oval watch League was asking
underage women for nude photos she then
continues to describe the first time
they ever spent time together face to
face which was at twitchcon during that
explanation she describes multiple
alleged instances of movement being
physically and verbally inappropriate to
herself and other women these
accusations include unwanted touching
unprovoked attempts at kissing and
grabbing women's wrists so hard that it
left bruised she then went on to allege
that after those incidents at twitchcon
muffinhead quote gone on an apology
spree for any bad behavior because he
had been DMing underage girls sexually
and a girl and others had posted about
it on their private Twitter's end quote
she then went on to accused moo-ving of
bullying some of these underage girls
until deleting evidence that would prove
the
allegations were true she also included
a screenshot which she says is muffin
offering to build someone a PC who was
calling him out for soliciting news from
underage girls in addition to that
screenshot there are multiple others
that help corroborate the information
she puts forth in the Twitter longer now
of course all these accusations are very
serious and on top of all of that police
he actually reiterated the same
sentiment as before that blizzard and
the Boston uprising have been made aware
of this all before she went public with
the information as to why she's coming
forward with this information now well
she says after she made blizzard aware
they just didn't do enough and at this
point we can't confirm that they've done
anything publicly here's what she had to
say quote I feel I need to go public
with the information that I have now
because this man is actively continuing
his predatorial ways while being
highlighted in the community by his
involvement with overwatch League and
using his power and charm to hide a lot
of the evidence I believe women in the
community are at risk from this
individual end quote
so she makes this post and then Boston
ventures move it but since that original
allegation even more information has
come out about the situation police he
tweeted a story from a girl who was 17
at the time of her interaction with
movement who wished to remain anonymous
she said that move and sent her dick
pics and while she ended the
relationship he pressured her into
deleting the evidence of their
conversation there's also another
anecdote from Twitter from a girl whose
age were not sure about who says that
muffin used her for sex and then asked
her to keep quiet about the interaction
afterwards and then there's a second
massive twit longer from someone who was
at twitchcon with muffin and police and
corroborates a lot of the information
that was in the original telling of the
story this Pierson seems to be a friend
or at least was a friend of both police
and movement specifically she describes
his quote obsessiveness and the unwanted
touching that Khaleesi also described so
to recap
several women have come forward with
allegations that muffin was sexually
inappropriate to them and specifically
sexually inappropriate to underage women
since the uprisings notice removing
muffin from the roster last weekend
neither the uprising or the overwatch
League have provided any additional
information so far about this
investigation
Boston's next match is until next
Saturday April 11 and it still remains
to be seen whether or not
get an update on this situation before
they put move in himself has not made a
statement about these allegations and
hasn't been active on his personal
Twitter since this whole situation
started now this isn't actually the
first time a Boston uprising player has
faced allegations of this nature two
years ago during the overwatch league's
inaugural season Jonathan Sanchez known
in the league as dream Casper was
suspended and removed from the team this
is because a 14 year old girl accused
dream Casper of having an inappropriate
online relationship with her and
detailed the entire situation in a
Google Doc okay so that's all the
information we have so far about this
situation but if anything new comes from
the team the league or Blizzard
themselves will be sure to let you know
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]